merci monsieur le garde des sceaux la
parole et à monsieur eric straumann
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
votre secrétaire d'état madame ségolène
neuville annonciez faire fièrement le 12
octobre dernier dans cet hémicycle une
dotation supplémentaire de 50 millions
euros pour l'insertion des bénéficiaires
du rsa
ce montant représente en réalité un euro
soit 110 par mois pour chaque
bénéficiaire du rsa
quelles actions d'insertion voulez vous
menez avec un montant aussi ridicule la
vérité c'est que vous avez abandonné
toute volonté d'insertion des personnes
les plus vulnérables
la seule réponse et de caricaturer la
mesure décidée par le conseil
départemental du haut rhin qui cherche à
donner un avenir aux bénéficiaires du
rsa par une activité au service d'une
association ou d'une collectivité
publique car personne n'a vocation à
rester de manière indéfinie dans cette
situation pour permettre aux
départements les plus en difficulté face
à l'explosion du rsa le gouvernement a
annoncé la mise en place d'un fonds
d'urgence de 200 millions d'euros
ma question est la suivante sur quels
critères ces deux cents millions d'euros
seront distribués aux conseils
départementaux en quasi faillite et à
quelle date sera annoncée la liste des
heureux bénéficiaires
merci la parole est à madame ségolène
neuville secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées et de la lutte
contre l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député et straumann
à vrai dire il est assez savoureux de
recevoir des leçons d'un député qui est
président d'un conseil départemental qui
propose finalement pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa de son département
du bénévolat obligatoires on sait à quoi
cela aboutit le tribunal a tranché il y
a quelques jours et donc tout
naturellement le gouvernement s'est
interrogé effectivement
les inégalités en termes de politique
d'insertion dans les départements nous
avons fait ce travail avec jean michel
baylet bien sûr parce que la réalité
c'est que les politiques d'insertion
sont extrêmement différenciée d'un
département à l'autre
il ya certains départements où
effectivement il ya beaucoup qui est
fait et d'autres départements où les
choix politiques sont complètement
différents et où il ya bien peu qu'ils
aient fait vous avez une vision
restrictive d'aidé restrictif des choses
vous pensez que les politiques
d'insertion
c'est uniquement en direction des
bénéficiaires du rsa
monsieur le député c'est bien plus large
que ça alors évidemment c'est votre
compétence obligatoire mais néanmoins il
y a des gens qui sont sortis du rsa ou
d'autres qui vont y rentrer et on voit
bien que c'est beaucoup plus large
l'ambition de ce gouvernement c'est
précisément que les départements qui
sont reconnus comme les chefs de file de
l'action sociale
et bien soit les chefs de file de
l'insertion mais avec l'état avec les
missions locales avec les caf avec
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux qui
travaillent sur l'insertion et oui
l'état a décidé de s'engager avec 50
millions d'euros supplémentaires mais
supplémentaires par rapport à tout le
reste pour les départements qui
souhaiteront s'engager et je ne doute
pas que ce député que votre département
souhaitera s'engager car votre
département veut travailler sur
l'insertion sûrement c'est ce que vous
allez nous faire croire aujourd'hui donc
c'est ça la réalité c'est la différence
entre les politiques de droite et de
gauche nous ne nous engageons dans la
lutte contre les contre l'exclusion pas
vous